welcome
to this free webinar on bioinformatics
for
infectious diseases in today's webinar
we will speak about bioinformatics for
infectious disease research
and present use cases for bioinformatics
analysis methods
that are used in viral evolutionary
studies
antiviral drug discovery as well as the
emergence of drug resistance in
bacterial pathogens
we will also showcase some of the latest
developments
of the t info platform designed for
biology studies and introduced the
upcoming omics logic training programs
for those
interested in effective utilization of
bioinformatics
for infectious diseases immunology and
microbiology
my name is beepsha biswas and i'm the
omixlogic community manager
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users that are part of our
community managed by pine biotech
over the past couple of years we have
seen participants from
all over the world join our training
programs
take online coursework and utilize
our big data analysis tools in various
research projects
what we will discuss today and
throughout
this webinar is a result of hard work by
an amazing team
led by company co-founders dr alfred
tauber
and dr djonet prosky
dr tober comes from a medical background
and has
extensive expertise in archaeology
immunology and biochemistry
of inflammation and has been recognized
internationally for his generous support
of many research projects and
initiatives that support
training and applications in medicine dr
leonid brodsky is the director of the
tubber bioinformatics research center
at haifa and is an expert in
bioinformatics and biostatistics he has
numerous publications in mathematics
and bioinformatics and over the course
of his career has developed
multiple novel algorithmic approaches to
biomedical data analysis
the rest of the team you see here
includes experts in bioinformatics
computer science and training
and some of our team will be presenting
today as well
in the upcoming omits logic program you
will have the opportunity
to interact and collaborate with an
international team of experts
specialized in the application of data
science
to biological data sets let me introduce
to the main speakers for today's session
dr harpreet kaur
is a certified omixlogic trainer and
expert by information who will guide
the hands-on sessions and assist
participants with
projects and analysis during the program
her
area of specialization is in genomics
and machine learning
dr mohit mazumdar is a raw mixed logic
project mentor
and an expert in big data computational
analysis
dr mazumdar has a phd in computational
biology and over 10 years of
experience working with industry and
academia
elia brodsky is our co-founder and ceo
at pinebiotic
in his current role he has extensive
experience working together
with industry and academic partners that
are applying multiomics
integration and bioinformatics to a
variety of biotechnology
and clinical applications i will pass it
on to elia
to talk about the increasing role of
bioinformatics and data science in
infectious disease research
and introduce you to the types of
challenges data analysis
data organization integration and
visualization can
solve for biomedical research projects
uh over to you elia
thank you
share my screen
thank you very much pizza uh my name is
elia bronski i'm the co-founder and ceo
of pine biotech
and i want to share with you today a
little bit of a perspective of what role
bioinformatics is playing
in different aspects of infectious
disease
research and would like to also
introduce
a couple of tools that we have designed
and developed
for this kind of study to help
understand the relationship between
genomic and ohmic data in general with
various aspects of infectious diseases
genomics and bioinformatics have
contributed
immensely to our understanding of
infectious diseases
from disease pathogenesis or how the
disease develops over time
to the understanding of how disease
happens or what are the mechanisms of
interaction between
the pathogen and the host the spread
of bacterial and viral
antimicrobial resistance and antiviral
resistance
as well as the host immune response so
how does our body respond
to these challenges posed by these
pathogens
as a result infectious diseases has been
one of the areas
where genomic medicine has changed
the way we interact with pathogens
detect them characterize them and
develop
treatments and prevention strategies for
these important diseases and so as a
result
this the application of bioinformatics
to omix data has substantially advanced
our ability to detect
study and treat infectious diseases and
the achievements
came as a result of a close
collaboration
or an increasingly close collaboration
between computer scientists and
biologists
placing bioinformatics i believe at the
center
of these current advances in this domain
and so i hope that
in this presentation you will also be
able to see
and appreciate the role of
bioinformatics and how diverse
bioinformatics applications
in application to infectious diseases
are
so there's an increasing need in
mastering bioinformatics skills
to be able to conduct such research
so the omics data that is now regularly
being used to study viral
genomes dna variation host gene
expression
protein abundance and composition
properties of microbial communities
they really require very different types
of approaches to dealing with this kind
of data to be
able to effectively study and mine this
data for patterns
and really understand the pathogens and
their interaction with the hosts
so today we'll take a look at several
examples of these kinds of data sets
and how they apply to key examples
that we will discuss so the role of
bioinformatics in general
and in the context of infectious
diseases is really to allow
researchers to access process
analyze and visualize these kinds of
high
throughput data and so i will introduce
several examples of how this was done
successfully by researchers that are
studying
viral infections like the ebola virus
outbreak in west africa
coven 19 pandemic as well as microbial
pathogens that cause tuberculosis and
malaria
we will briefly touch on viral genomics
and evolution
as well as the analysis of gene
expression patterns
for detection of significant genomic
variants
as well as important aspects of the
microbiome and the viral so really not
just individual pathogens
but whole communities in a host that are
being studied to find important
associations
with disease susceptibility as well as
outcomes
in the last 20 years availability of
genomic data
has led to an increasing understanding
of how
cells function at the molecular level
and
has allowed us to understand some of the
major causes of deadly diseases
that affect humanity around the world
with the current rise in viral outbreaks
and their deadliness
there's a major focus on developing
tools
data repositories and data sets
for better understanding of the
emergence prevention and treatment of
infectious diseases
so in fact you can see here that
in 2020 the coronavirus
disease obviously has captured the
attention of
researchers around the world placing it
as
one of the prominent uh causes of death
but nevertheless many of the diseases
that you see here
listed have some kind of a pathogen
behind them for example you can see here
tuberculosis
hiv and aids malaria
meningitis and so there are a lot of
different hepatitis
there are a lot of different infectious
diseases
diarrheal diseases that are listed here
that are
leading causes of death
importantly we can see how the field
of virology and microbiology has
developed over time
and you can easily see it in this
illustration where we see
in 2002 one of the first
review of viral metagenomics
where the application of metagenomic
sequences
was highlighted to study viruses
and the communities of viruses that they
live in
and eventually leading us to 2020
where there has been an explosion in
publications
all based on analysis of sequencing data
so what's happening and this is an
important trend that i wanted to
highlight
is that sequencing technologies and the
ability to
analyze genomic data has
led to an increasing abundance of
structured data sets that are
easy to navigate to find data and mine
that data
to study important and happening right
now
events right so if previously it took
a long time before identification
of a particular challenge to then
finding the right data
or developing that data set or a
database
and then eventually coming with
conclusions about the analysis of that
data
today that's happening almost in real
time
so regularly researchers studying covet
19
are generating data that is not
necessarily
as a result of an experiment but just
generating data from patients and from
different types of
experiments that are being conducted
regularly placing it
into repositories that we all can access
and applying these tools to extract some
meaningful patterns that immediately can
lead
to insights about how is this pandemic
developing over time
and what are some of the important
features or characteristics
that we can focus on to prevent
treat or understand this disease better
and importantly i think that this
trend over time has highlighted
some of the important ways that we are
starting to think
differently about these pathogens not
only as individual elements individual
genomes but really also as communities
of microbes of microorganisms
viruses and bacteria that live together
and interact
and surround us every step of the way
and so there has to be
a greater appreciation for the way that
the host
and the pathogen interact leading to
emergence
of such deadly diseases as copit19
and making some parts of the population
much more susceptible
to be infected and lead to
much more deadly outcomes so really it
has led
all of this data and all of these
data sets that have been collected have
really
changed the way that we think
about viruses bacteria and other
pathogens
and so one important emergence of
this kind of an understanding has been
the appreciation of the vine rome
which is the part of the microbiome and
constitutes
all of the organisms that inhibit
inhabit us
so the the microbiome includes
all the microorganisms that inhabit the
human body
that include bacterial and archaeal
organisms
as well as the microbiome and other
members of the mayo fauna
such as protists and metazones
studies of the viron are really in their
infancy
because it has only become possible
recently
to see the virum in large sequence data
sets
using bioinformatics tools that can
detect relationships between viruses
despite this high nucleotide sequence
diversity
so in fact the size of the mammalian
biarm is not even known
although our own cells are outnumbered
about 10-fold by our
bacterial microbiome the number of
viruses may be
10-fold higher still human feces alone
contain over
10 to the 8th or 10th to the 9th of
viruses per gram
additionally the mammalian virum is
continuously updated through rapid
evolution of viruses
and through exposure to viruses in the
environment or in other
mammals so one of the leading reasons
why we can now appreciate the role of
individual pathogens as well as study
them
as communities in their natural
environment
is the ability to sequence and
understand
the variability of genomic data present
in a given sample
so let's talk a little bit about one of
the major technologies that has
made this possible and the technology of
course is next generation sequencing
now the way next generation sequencing
is used
is also changing it has been highly
expensive
and prohibitive in cases but today
the size of the instruments the ease of
use of those
instruments as well as the cost
association with
associated with producing high quality
data
have led to an explosion in next
generation sequencing data
one of the challenges with next
generation sequencing data is that it is
still
large and requires specifically designed
tools to be able to extract meaningful
patterns
and find associations between short
sequences
and phenotypes and so let's
talk a little bit about what are some of
these associations and what kind of
metagenomic data
are available to study infectious
diseases
to study metagenomic data
and to understand the composition of
this data
there are really several different
techniques that could be used
at the sequencing stage first
we can speak about targeted sequencing
in other words we can select a
particular organism or a
type of an organism we can prepare
specific adapters that target
sequences unique to that individual
organism or group of organisms
amplify and then study sequence
variation knowing what we are going
after
the second approach is the amplicon
so amplicon sequencing is
typically used to amplify a particular
region
and that region might be useful to
understand
variability between different organisms
present in a sample for example
amplicon sequencing is hugely
popular with metagenomics when we speak
about bacteria the 16s
ribosomal rna or other genes
have what's called hypervariable regions
or regions that
allow us to study a taxonomic
composition of samples
without having the full genomes
sequenced and assembled which is a major
challenge
because so many of the genomes do not
have a reference
another approach is to sequence the
whole dna
or rna so we can extract
all of the dna or rna present in the
sample
sequence it and then within all of that
information to look for particular
types of genomes or genomic elements
and characterize what we have and
quantify how much of it do we have
so these are very different approaches
that allow us to extract
very different types of information from
a given sample
for example one of the challenges with
targeted sequencing
is that we are not accurately
characterizing how much
of that particular element do we have in
our sample
at the same time with the whole dna and
rna sequencing
it becomes very expensive because we are
sequencing everything
and we are assuming that a lot of what
we are sequencing is not going to be
useful
if we are focused on the study of a
particular pathogen
so to understand how to find the right
kind of data or maybe how to
sequence the right kind of data and then
how to analyze
that data with the right kinds of
methods we really need to go behind
some of the black box methods that are
typically used in bioinformatics
to understand the logic behind these
analysis methods
and apply that logic to a few different
examples
that will illustrate what this type of
data can give us
for example to study
microbial and viral pathogens
several different types of sequencing
have been applied
with different types of analysis
pathways or
pipelines to understand different
aspects
of the pathogen or the microorganism
that is causing
a disease to the community within which
it is causing that disease so what other
microorganisms
it interacts with to then potentially
understanding how that
pathogen responds to different
challenges
applied to its natural environment and
those challenges could come
from treatment from the immune system
or from competition with other pathogens
within its environment so this kind of
sequencing has been applied
to both viral outbreaks to study them
in real time and understand how they are
changing over time as well as to
kind of persistent infections including
hiv
malaria tuberculosis and other pathogens
that are regularly treated and therefore
they are highly likely to evolve and
change the way that they interact with
the
environment because of those uh
pressures so here we have two examples
one speaks about viral outbreaks
where we can take a direct clinical
specimen
and within that specimen that comes with
all of the present organisms that are
there we could either
amplify for specific viral
sequences and therefore study the
specific
changes in the virus genome using sander
sequencing
or using illumina sequencing we can take
all of the present material a line
the virus reads or align all of the
reeds to a
virus reference genome or a database of
viral genomes
and then try to understand what
what kind of viral populations are
present in a sample
in this case we see a number of
different types of
applications of metagenomic sequencing
to study
different aspects of pathogens and how
they interact with the human body
so for example we can use it to identify
a specific strain out of all possible
strains to detect
and really characterize what does that
strain look like
we can also look for specific mutations
or genes that are known to be associated
with different phenotypes including
resistance to different treatments and
drugs
and looking at the composition
of different viral sequences
present in a sample we can even predict
the emergence of a particular group of
those
viruses that will become dominant and
will
have an antiviral resistance
characteristic to them we can also look
at the microbiome so instead of looking
at individual pathogens look at full
communities
where we can compare healthy and sick or
healthy and different types of
phenotypes and really compare and
contrast those conditions to understand
how at the genomic level
we can find different types of
taxonomic organizational representatives
so different types of taxonomies
that can help us understand how these
communities might be related
to a phenotype or to a condition and
then finally we can look at
transcriptomic data so we can look at
the immune response or the
response of a cell to that pathogen to
understand
how that pathogen modulates the response
as well as to understand what kind of
basic
inflammatory processes and immune
response
pathways are activated and whether they
are effective
or what other types of maybe adverse
response that might cause so to really
look at the variety of insights we can
gain from such genomic data
we really need to understand what this
data looks like
so here i have an example of what
the sequencing produces so the process
of sequencing
is really the process of generating
short reads
here individual lines that you see are
short reads
that typically are mapped to some kind
of a
reference and the mapping process
is very dependent on the quality of
these
reads of the sequences within the each
of the short reads that we have here
and the abundance of those reads so the
higher the abundance
the more confident we can be that we are
finding
very accurate signal and then we can
trust the changes that we observe in the
signal to understand
what kinds of mutations or variants are
emerging
in the sequence and also what kind of
variation
we observe between different potential
representatives
of this kind of symbol
[Music]
you have muted
okay am i unmuted now
uh yes you're unmuted
okay so when we have this raw
sequencing data one of the major
challenges
is to really apply the understanding
of what kind of variation we have to a
detailed understanding of what does
genome actually contains for example in
the case of the novel coronavirus
we need to understand the properties of
the different
sequence elements or genomic elements
that encode
for different types of genes or
protein-producing genes
or even helper genes so sequences that
don't necessarily become
proteins but they assist in the process
of replication
so from going to go from
the raw sequence reads to be able to say
something meaningful about what we
observe
and the variation that we observe we
really have to capture the data
have reference information about
reference genomes
and what those reference genomes code
for
and then we have to piece together the
different information that we have
about the pathogen itself how it
interacts
with its environment and what is the
response of the host
that we can measure and quantify so
let's talk a little bit more
about some of the analysis methods that
are useful
for this kind of genomic and
transcriptomic data
so today we will speak about four
different examples of methods of
analysis that are useful
to be able to study these kinds of viral
and microbial infections and what
and let's think about what they can
produce
as we discover associations and patterns
in search data so we'll talk about
analysis methods and
tools for genomic and transcriptomic
data analysis of
host pathogen interaction for example
methods to study
relationships based on local and global
multiple sequence alignment what's
called
msa phylogenetic analysis
and evolutionary studies used for genome
ancestry and population fitness
chemical and structural implications of
sequence variation mapped
on pdb models or models of proteins that
we know of
and host pathogen interaction and
treatment response
based on transcriptomic data
to speak about these different tools we
have prepared
different sections on the t-barn for
platform
that you can easily explore and quickly
apply to different types of data sets
using the t-biome for platform that has
a visual
interface so let's go to that platform
if you could please post the link
on the chat i'm going to open the chat
okay so please go with me to server.t
bio dot info
thank you beepset
what you see here is a section
of areas of analysis really this
represents
different types of methods
bioinformatics methods
to understand and study such
variation at the molecular level so
please let me know
once you're on this link and it has
opened up for you
you can just put number one in the chat
or say okay or yes i'm there
and i will know that at least a few of
you are there
so we'll take a little look at some of
these tools
okay excellent thank you very much so i
see that many of you are here
so now just to explain anyone
that is interested in using some of
these tools in the context of
research or education you're welcome to
request an account you can actually get
a free account as a demo
to understand how this tool works but
i'll briefly showcase today
several aspects of this type of research
that could be done on the platform using
a visual interface and then i'll
transition a little bit
to go behind the scenes and show you how
these tools
work so first of all what you see is
a few different sections right here and
one important one
is this access form so
if you are interested in using this tool
in the future
after this session please fill this out
fill out this information
and we will reach out back to you by
email
to understand what exactly are you
looking for
for some of you you might be our
previous customers or participants with
different programs
so if you do have your login information
you're welcome to log
in okay
thank you beeps okay
so let's take a look today at several
different
aspects and i'll just first highlight
those sections here so all of you can
easily find them
so we talked about genomic variation
transcriptomic variation analysis
of phylogenetic relationships or
phylogeny
and then also host pathogen host
pathogen
interaction so we have here several
different sections for example here
under phylogenetic tree
and you can open up here an example
in this example we'll briefly speak
about
how you can go from raw sequencing reads
to understand the phylogenetic
relationship between sequences and these
sequences could be
genes or whole genomes
we will also speak briefly about how
you can conduct an analysis of
viral host path host pathogen
interaction so here you can see
an additional level of highly
detailed molecular data that allows us
to understand
emerging mutations and characterize
fitness
of virus populations
we will also speak about viral
quasi species that allows us to
look at point mutations
defective viral genomes and also to link
that
to different types of genomic variation
at the phylogenetic level finally
we will speak about transcriptomic data
analysis
so using analysis of rna-seq data
we will take a look at how you can
understand
response to treatment response to
pathogen
infection and characterize the immune
response by looking at
pathways and genes that are involved in
that response
so first of all let's look at what
genomic data looks like
and how we can find any kind of
variation
within this data so if you don't have an
account
um you won't be able to do this at the
same time as i do
but later on if you are interested in
repeating this demo
on your own we are happy to send you a
demo account so you'll have a login and
a password to come in and do exactly the
steps that i do
we're not going for the sake of time
we're not going to do it together
because we have a lot of participants
but in the future after you review the
recording you'll be able to do that so
please
request your demo account
by filling out this form if you would
like to do that
okay what i'm going to do is i'm going
to go into this section for a mutation
variant
and i'm just going to give you an
example how you can go from
genomic sequencing so sequences
of dna or rna
mapped onto the reference genome so here
we use
bow tie two to map to the reference
genome
and then producing results in a visual
format so as a result of mapping on the
reference genome i'm going to get
a sam or a bam file and that sam
or a bam file is going to show me
what is in the reads so let's take a
look here i'm going to load the jb
browse application for the results of
this pipeline and the results will be
loaded in such a way that i can easily
navigate them and find what's in my data
okay so what's important here is to be
able to understand
what this data represents so let's
zoom in a little bit and we'll kind of
take a look
at what we can see here as you can see
each sample represents millions
and millions of reads and these are
individual
reads that we can look into that have a
sequence
with a t c and g
and those sequences are mapped onto a
reference genome so in this case this is
the human
genome with variable coverage
allowing us to find variation
or changes that are significant
from the reference genome so for example
here we can see this
green little marker and this marker
represents
a snip or a variant that we can study
so we can look in and we can see
what is this variance so we can for
example uh
zoom in a little bit more here
okay and we can see what this variant in
is
now one of the challenges of analysis
is to be able to map all of these reads
to the reference genome
identify such variation and then
importantly
maybe most importantly is to find what
might be the association between
this particular change and some kind of
a phenotype
the other use case here and let me do
another quick demonstration here is when
our reference is one organism for
example the host
but our input data
we suspect has sequencing reads from
both the host
and the pathogen so here i'm going to
do some pre-processing on my data and
then i'm going to
again map it on to okay sorry right here
i'm just going to go
quickly to another section
and i'm going to perform essentially the
same process i'm going to map
on the reference genome and
find the visualization tool and look at
a different type of a sequence sequence
that was mapped
to be able to identify
a particular type of a genome
okay so here you can see again this data
is being mapped and i can see the reads
but importantly when i go into the
results
i will be able to find not only
what is in my data but also to find the
individual reads and the percentage
of how many of those reads were mapped
onto the reference genome
using such technique i will be able to
identify
potential pathogens from a viral
or a microbial database that i could
then study
in a more detailed way
now another section that we will look at
today
is a section that has to do with
multiple
sequence alignment so let's take a look
right here under phylogenetic tree
we can look right here what is this
section
designed to do what the section does
is load in genomic sequences
and those genomic sequences contain
maybe a variety of different viruses
from the same family
or maybe it contains individual reads
from patient samples and we can then
either work with fast q files
based on sequencing reads or we can
align the genomic data to perform
multiple sequence alignments
and understand what is in our data
either as a relationship between
multiple uh viral sequences for example
or as haplotypes that you can
study for variability and find
association
with a particular phenotype
so this is an example where we can look
at haplotypes
or there's an example where you can
actually look
at
let me go back here where you can look
at
the specific relationships
between viral sequences so using
multiple sequence alignments
and then converting those sequences to
amino acids
and then understanding variability using
all kinds of phylogenetic methods that
i'll talk about in a second
to really understand variability between
genomic sequences so let's take a look
at the meaning of some of these basic
analysis methods and how they could be
used to study
the genomic variation so
at the basis of all of these analysis
methods
is what's called multiple sequence
alignments
and so here you can see the idea of
multiple sequence alignment when we take
multiple reads or multiple genomes
we make sure that they align to each
other
in such a way that maximum similarity
is is on
average uh achieved between the full
sequences we then identify
specific variations and those could be
variations at the
nucleotide level or the amino acid level
and then we characterize those mutations
to understand
what types of mutations are we finding
importantly when we deal with next
generation sequencing
we are going to find a challenge of
characterizing
those uh changes that only have
low coverage so the higher the coverage
it's important for us to achieve a high
coverage to be able to
be confident in the changes that we
observe
once we observe those we can then start
characterizing them by associating them
with a particular phenotype for example
hi elia uh we are not able to hear you
um probably
a technical error on your end
give us a minute everyone i guess there
is a problem on his end
yeah thank you so much mo it will just
be back shortly
okay so i think elia has
uh some kind of problem on his end
which i will be uh having a look at so
the session
is not over yet
yes hi yep sorry about that something
happened here with my network let me try
sharing yeah
yeah thank you can you see my screen
yes yeah we can see your screen thank
you
okay okay sorry if my
uh network here for some reason became a
little bit unstable
so again to be able to understand
what process is causing these variants
or what are these variants associated
with
we need to touch on the biology of the
pathogen itself
because in each case with each different
pathogen that we're talking about
there's going to be a variety of factors
that we need to consider
for example when we speak about viral
infections we have a
basic entry of the pathogen
into a cell with the objective to
hijack the host machinery to produce
viral proteins
assemble them and eventually
produce multiple replicates of the same
virus
now to really go into the detail of this
process
not only is the energy difference
between different types of viruses
but also these viruses are not
homogeneous they actually represent
a community of various types of
sequences
and so one of the questions is whether
one of those particular
types of genomes that are entering the
cell
eventually lead to a variety of
the different types of pathogens that
exit the cell
and what are the different immune
responses or strategies that the virus
has to adapt
and avoid or evade the immune response
of the host
so when we study genomic variation
for the different pathogens we are
actually
thinking of how these particular
mutations
that we observe in the sequences that
are captured
represent a relationship between
the ancestor or the sequence that
entered
into the host and the
present day species that we observe
and the way to understand the
relationships is to map
the different groups or genomes
that we have into what's called a
phylogenetic tree
this phylogenetic tree can help us
map the differences between genomic
sequences
in such a way that we can associate it
with a process
a process of going from a single
ancestor
to then dividing up into branches
just like a family tree would that we
can
study for variability and distance
evolutionary distance between each
one of our members in the data
and the potential common ancestor that
they might have
so what kind of information can such an
analysis yield this is an example
of a phylogenetic analysis of the
2016 outbreak of the ebola virus in west
africa
here you can see and this has been done
obviously for
many other viruses including covet 19 so
here you can see from 2014 to 2015
we can see one single type
of the original pathogen that started
this epidemic
and eventually split up into multiple
clades
and some of those clades were more fit
they were more capable therefore we have
observed them to be
more present in later days and
some of them we can now start thinking
about
well which geographic locations
were they more prevalent in obviously in
each one of our
geographic locations we have different
types of
phenotypes for people for treatments
for the way people interact for the
different
death rates for the infection rates
etc etc so now we have an ability to
structure our data
and study evolution of the virus
its ability to adapt to different types
of
responses the common origin right one of
the questions could be
did it all start from just one single
location and which
location did it start from and which
location
did the transfer happen at as well as
the divergence right so what might be
some
factors that contributed to this highly
divergent phylogenetic
tree at the end of that process
now as i mentioned this type of analysis
is also very effective not just for
this particular case of the ebola virus
but also here beneath we can see
a similar analysis for coven 19.
so for covet 19 an initial analysis was
largely focused
on how we can study such type of
variation
between different known species of the
coronaviruses like stars one
and mers as well as some of the
novel emergent pathogens that we are
starting to see
beyond that first characterization of
covet 19 for example
in other animals what might be a
potential host reservoir
that we should be cautious with
so one of the things that we can do with
such information
is not only look at sequence similarity
but start looking at which particular
regions of the genome
show us more or less variation
and what kind of consequence does that
variation have
at the amino acid level at the level
where it actually
codes for a protein therefore having a
functional capacity
so one of the things that have emerged
from the very beginning
is that such variability in the case of
cobit 19
was not uniform it was not the same
across the full genome so if you look
down here
at this figure c you can see
the nucleotide identity or how similar
different genomes are to each other
or to a single reference and you can see
the dips
right so these are lower areas that show
that there's
much less consensus so they're more
divergent they're different
and the differences now have to be
mapped to the different
particular proteins that are encoded in
those genes
so probably many of you have already
heard about the spike
glycoprotein the protein that is
responsible for
viral entry into the host cell and we
can see that
this particular dip happens right here
with the spike protein and here you can
see another dip that is less than that
but also this happens at the end protein
so now we can think about
well what might be the consequence
of such changes in association
with protein function
when we want to understand protein
function there are several ways that we
can deal
with that variation ultimately relying
on again
genomic data so we talked briefly about
how nucleotide level similarity can
inform us about
amino acid level sequence similarity
when we look at the sequence similarity
we can look
at genomic context or features
right so if we know where this
particular genomic element is being
expressed
or what is its functional class or we
can compare
global and local sequence similarity
these can be tools in our toolkit
to study amino acid variation based on
nucleotide variation found directly in
the genomic data
the second option that we have is to
understand the 3d structure so
ultimately when we have
a sequence that sequence gets translated
into an amino
acid sequence because it folds and the
amino acid folding
happens based on physical chemical
properties
so how the different amino acids
could be put together into an actual
structure that is going to become
functional
now here we also have some tools to
identify different types of
functional elements or motifs
that we know and have characterized in
the past
we can also look at the actual structure
of this protein if it is available
and try to understand the implication of
nucleotide variation
on the properties of the overall
structure
another method and we'll talk about this
in just a second
is to generate high throughput data so
we can
generate data on gene expression for
example by
taking out a particular gene or a
protein or a portion of a protein or
introducing a mutation
that will cause a stop codon that will
lead to a stop codon and shorten the
protein
and now we can study differential gene
expression analysis
which will reveal how the expressed
properties of that protein have changed
after we have introduced that
modification
so really those are the three elements
that we can connect and combine together
to have a full overview of what is going
on
now importantly a lot of this data is
already available online so we talked a
little bit about different
tools let's speak a little bit about
different resources
that you can find to understand
what kind of genomic information is
available
and how you can start right away
to develop an idea or a project
for a particular type of a pathogen okay
so let's go quickly to ncbi virus
please go to go with me to ncbi
virus i'm just going to paste the link
right here in chat
okay please let me know once you've
arrived at ncbi virus
okay thank you michael if you could
please put in chat that you've
arrived here yes please put number one
or number two
excellent so now that you're here right
the reason i'm saying too is because we
already had
our first uh link which was the server
where we analyzed data and this is now
our second destination the second
destination is where do we actually find
the data
okay so for those of you that got here
obviously
you have a quick access to source code 2
data
but importantly the data set includes a
variety of different pathogens and here
we're just focusing on different viruses
so here we'll quickly see a number of
different
viral sequences that are available so if
you look
on search by virus if you click on
search by virus
think of any virus coronavirus influenza
hepatitis ebola virus so really
any virus that you can think of and just
place it right
here i'm just going to place your ebola
virus
just give it a couple of seconds
and you will see that this drop down
appears
where you have different subtypes of
that family
the ebola virus family and here are the
different types of the ebola viruses
so for example we can see here zaire
ebola virus
so once you click on that particular
type
you can now see the different data sets
that are available
so by looking at this data
please let me know how many nucleotide
sequences
are available for this ebola virus
for the zaire ebola virus you you should
be able to find
on this page how many nucleotide
sequences are available excellent thank
you chandra
prakash uh was the first one so
you get a special call out there okay so
2938 so almost
3 000 viral sequences
for ebola virus for those of you that
are interested
let's take a look and instead of the
zaire ebola virus then we can just
remove this and here add another plus
and let's search for corona virus
so you can see the coronavirude family
and and now uh tell me how many
are available for the coronavir day
family
all right great noun
got it first so special call out to now
69 000 sequences uh now who remembers
when did the ebola virus epidemic really
uh start uh you know as a big concern
how many of you remember uh the ebola
virus outbreak
okay 2008 2016. okay really
2014 is when it started
there have been outbreaks before that
okay so i see mohit
uh misra got the the first right answer
there
2014 to 2016 was really the outbreak so
start around 2014. now if you think
about it we're in 2020 that's just six
years ago
so we've had this ongoing research of
the ebola virus
and the sequencing uh change really the
way that sequencing was used directly
during the outbreak
is that first outbreak of ebola virus
because
of several different reasons so in
previous outbreaks of the ebola virus
like in the 1960s
mentioned here by a beer 1970s i think
is when it was
you had very expensive and highly
laborious process of generating those
sequences
and so as a result those sequences
accumulated fairly slowly
but in 2014 to 2016 there was also an
emergence of
oxford nanopore sequencing which was
very affordable
it was not very accurate but you could
literally take it to the field and take
a sample
and sequence it right there in the
matter of maybe half an
hour so as a result there has been an
emergence of this
real time sequencing data about a
pandemic that was going on
and many many labs around the world were
focused on
analyzing those sequences to extract
meaningful
information that will guide the
detection characterization
treatment and prevention strategies
ultimately resulting
in a vaccine and not so long ago an
antiviral treatment for the ebola virus
as opposed to today right you can see
the rate at which this is happening
right so remember 2014 six years ago
today we're in 2020 so from 2020
from maybe december 2019 but ultimately
in 2020 so we're just talking about a
matter of months
we already have almost 70 000 sequences
so when we have 70 000 sequences
the challenge is not in generating the
data anymore
the challenge is in analyzing this data
to understand what it means and so
that's why
i think for any one of us that is
interested in such an
understanding not only do we have
really an explosion of data that is
available
on viral genomic sequences
on home bio projects that give us access
to different levels of information about
both
the pathogen and the host as well as
the specific characterization
of even protein sequences that we can
access through pdb so we're not just
looking at the level of genomic
similarity
we're also starting to look at what does
this genomic
information tell us about the variation
of key proteins of these pathogens
that actually interact with the host
proteins as well
so here you can see the spike protein
and the spike protein
mapped with mutation frequency
based on the analysis of different types
of corona viruses and specifically
cognitive
compared to low mortality rate
coronaviruses
where we can start to get an
understanding of how
different elements of this spike protein
the ones that interact with the
binding the ones that do cell fusion
so we really can apply our understanding
of the
real world situation
with that genomic data right so
combining those two
types of data together and ultimately
this kind of understanding
can have a profound effect on our
ability to characterize transmission
detect when the transmission happened
and how it happened
how we can think about different types
of intermediate hosts
and potential intermediate hosts
as well as thinking about actual biology
at the molecular level
where we have the receptors the immune
response and the interaction with the
immune response
tissue tropism so how the virus adapts
to different
types of tissues and tissue barriers to
ultimately design
different types of intervention
strategies
to try and address the current epidemic
now importantly that we need to
link all of this information to a
quantifiable process and in this case we
can have
a quantifiable process of the rate of
mutation
linked to our biological understanding
of how the rate of mutation in the
mutations themselves
affect the particular regions on the
proteins that we can study
for example we just looked at the spike
protein
one of the regions within the spike
proteins that has
the most variability between the high
and the low
death rate associated coronaviruses
is what's called the receptor binding
domain this
receptor binding domain is really a part
of the s1 subunit
that is located within the spike
glycoprotein sequence so it has several
different
functional domains and these functional
domains have
different rates of mutation
so those variations that we observe at
the genomic level
they are happening in different rates in
different portions
of this protein and to understand
what they might mean we can really start
taking a look
at the receptor so this is the host
receptor right here that you can see in
the blue
is the h2 receptor and you can have
uh the spike protein actually bind it
now
the spike this uh h2 receptor
actually sits within the host cell
membrane
just like that and
this sodium dependent neutral amino acid
transporter is what holds this acetyl
receptor in place
when the virus comes this is the spike
glycoprotein it is protruded from out of
the membrane of the virus
and it has this particular receptor
binding domain which is colored in red
here
amazingly we have all of these
structures
already available and so because
we have all of these structural elements
available
all of the genomic data that we have can
be highly informative
as we study protein protein interaction
so the interaction between the spike
protein and its receptor binding domain
to this particular protein called h2
okay so i'm going to pause here for a
second and i wanted to see if there are
any questions that i can address at this
time
ilya there are a few questions which i
have
so we have one from kehinde adesina
please what's the best sequencing
platform for microbiome analysis
and do you have any guide on using
nanopore sequencing platform for
16s rrna sequencing
i would be working on this for my msc
research
okay thank you for that question um yeah
so
you know it's difficult to say what is
the best sequencing platform because
they have
different aspects of uh quality
of the actual sequence the cost which is
an important factor so it
determines how many sequences we can
make
and also how easy it is to work with
that data
so basically there i would say are three
or four different types of sequencing
data that you will find for this kind of
application there's
sanger sequences sequencing which is the
golden standard for long sequencing
you can have very accurate sequences but
the problem is that you need a lot of
annotation to be able to produce those
there is illuminous sequencing which
allows us to
find really a balance between high level
of accuracy
and short reads but it is a little bit
expensive however there is
my seek aluminum my seek platform
that allows this to and it's typically
used very
um popular for metagenomic data analysis
so 16s ribosomal rna
where you have a long read about 300 350
base pairs long
and you can use those to capture
one or two hyper variable regions so for
example v4 v6
v4 v9 you can use different combinations
to study taxonomic variability then you
have
oxford nanopore and i would also put
pac bio maybe in that category so oxford
nanopore is very affordable
easy to use the data has um you know
not it's not such high quality so you do
have a lot of
variability but it is useful to
characterize populations
right because in the case of metagenomic
studies you're not looking
at individual sequences individual
genomes you're really looking at
taxonomic variability and composition so
i think that is a very good platform to
use for metagenomic sequences
okay yes
okay uh so noel has a question
i'm planning to do a whole genome
sequencing of
a camp lyobacter do you have an user
friendly platform that may help me in
analysis of obtained data
yeah so what i showed today and i will
give another little example with the
ebola virus
here there are multiple different ways
that you can use
genomic sequences to understand what you
have found for example you might be
focused
on as i mentioned phylogenetic analysis
so
divergence of present day samples from
a potential common ancestor you
might also want to look at differences
between
different types of samples that you have
maybe associated with a different
phenotype like their geolocation
or resistance to different types of
treatments
so importantly you have to have the data
in certain formats to be able to use
these different types of analysis
one part of that data is the genomic
sequencing the other part of the data is
what do you want to associate it with
right so
we will i'll give here in a couple of
minutes another
two examples on ebola virus and on
tuberculosis
to kind of illustrate what is needed for
those analyses but yes once you have the
genomic sequences
that is a big part of the story and you
can do a lot with that sequencing
already
okay okay uh elia so we do have a few
more questions
uh one that uh we had from
uh dr manov jane uh the certificates
that we offer for the program he has a
question regarding that
if they have any traceability like
barcode or anything else
okay um yeah so we do have a
permanent link for those certificates i
will pass it on to beeps in just a few
minutes to speak about the
training program that will start in
november for
bioinformatics and infectious diseases
where many of these methods are going to
be covered
in greater detail with access to some
asynchronous
material as well as projects that we
have curated to be able to illustrate
some of these methods of analysis
but right now i just wanted to make sure
that i address the questions about the
topics that i was talking about
i see here in the chat okay
so regarding um okay i see here
um uh i
read a few papers regarding uh
neuroplanet one along with h2 receptor
that helps in code name gene infection
can give us
information about that so again there
are specific use cases
we will go into much greater detail
about the coronavirus the ebola virus
tuberculosis
malaria some other pathogens in our
upcoming program
uh where we will take the available data
and actually try to mine that for
patterns
i think that the key here is that in the
context of bioinformatics
we will not just analyze published
research so how
other people have done something but
we'll actually take that data
and analyze it ourselves to make sure
that
first of all we can arrive at similar
conclusions that they have
to understand the logic of how they
arrive from raw data
to such conclusions and then ask
additional questions that maybe they
have not
previously asked about how we can take
that research
further so i hope that for those of you
that are joining this session it's
really to give
you a glimpse into what kinds of data
sets
what kinds of methods of analysis what
kinds of questions
we're going to cover and highlight and
so maybe
before we jump into the program i'll
just briefly complete my slides and i'll
pass it on to vipsa
to speak a little bit more about
the registration process and and the
different resources
okay so i briefly wanted to mention that
when we have genomic data right now
already illustrated the process of
visualizing that data that just the
visualization
itself is not very
kind of clear because we need also
statistical analysis of that data
to be able to determine which ones of
the different
mutations or variants that we find are
actually
functionally significant and that was a
major objective
in the process of the pandemic or the
epidemic
of the 2014-2016 outbreak
to determine mutations that might be
associated with
airborne infection which in case of
ebola that has a very high mortality
rate was a great concern
as well as what types of variants are
going to have
an impact on the potentially developed
vaccine
so as we will cover in the program
we'll talk about the process of taking
those same mutations
that you can see that we visualized and
then doing some
statistical analysis for variant calling
and characterization of the genomic
variants
to be able to identify the mutations
that are
most significant as you can see right
here this is the actual
ebola sequencing data that were
later on used in the proteins that were
included in the testing of the
vaccine that was designed for the ebola
virus
now the same type of an approach i
mentioned that
data on one side could be genomic data
right and we just kind of
use here reference proteins that we have
structures of to understand the
impact of those variants we can also
look
at a different approach this is an
example of tuberculosis again we have
here
visualization and then characterization
of mutations
but on the other side if we have
data about response or
data about uh emergence of different
types
of mutations associated with
antimicrobial resistance
we can start thinking about linking
those two data
using two different approaches
one approach is what's called g was so
genome-wide association studies
associations
of multiple positions on the genome with
a
phenotype which require a lot of
genomes right so if we have hundreds or
maybe even
thousands of genomes let's say from
tuberculosis
and we have incidents of which groups of
genomes
are associated with different types of
treatments
and different types of emergence of
single drugs or multi-drug resistant
strains we can find statistically
significant associations
with regions so you can see here either
single
mutations or whole regions or multiple
mutations together
in different locations that cause such
resistance now obviously these are just
a few examples and we don't
have time in the context of this one
webinar to
go through many examples in great detail
but in the program and in all that we do
what we try to do is take data from
current and peer review publications
analyze the methods that the authors
have used
to come to the conclusions that they
have published
and then to try and extract additional
data sets and additional methods
to develop independent projects with
our research fellows and so i do want to
mention that the
program that we have been discussing
today is really
also kind of enriched and expanded
by the research fellows that have joined
a research fellowship and i'll
let beach to talk about that in a second
that have been able to find
very useful case studies and really look
at both artifacts
and signal in the data that they have
submitted on ncbi and other publicly
available repositories to really develop
interesting
uh findings from the different projects
that you can find online
now here you can see
here you can see some of those examples
uh for example this is a student
submitted
project proposal that we go through
together
during this upcoming program and i'll
let beeps
maybe take over here in a second to
speak about
some of the program resources that we
have prepared
for this upcoming program called omix
logic
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
so really what
i showed today is just a glimpse
of a omixlogic full program
that will focus on some of these
different examples of coronaviruses
ebola viruses rhinoviruses tuberculosis
and malaria causing pathogens to
develop an understanding of how to
logically connect
the tools and the data to produce
interesting results
that are going to be of significant
value
to uh the virology community
so to speak about some of the program
resources
i am going to pass it on to pizza
to explain how to register for the
program
and how to gain access to all of those
resources
over to you beeps thank you so much elia
let me share my screen here again
okay
so before we start talking about the
different resources i just want to give
you an
overview of the upcoming program the
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
so over the course of the past several
years our team
has been collaborating with a number of
academic institutions around the world
that have participated in content
evaluation
curriculum review and project design as
a result
the omits logic programs have been
thoroughly evaluated and unknown
to lead to excellent outcomes
importantly the programs are designed to
support students with minimal
bioinformatics background including
biology and biomedical studies majors as
well as faculty
interested in bioinformatics data
science
and biomedical research
we have designed this program to
introduce the data resources
and tools that you can use to apply
bioinformatics to publicly available
data
on infectious diseases in this program
we will understand viral diversity and
its role in epidemic infectious diseases
that
keep re-emerging including zoonotic
transmission
transmission between humans and the
process of viral and bacterial disease
development
as elia demonstrated earlier we'll learn
about bioinformatics analysis approaches
to study viral genomes
and understand the relationships between
viral streams haplotypes finding
differences
in sequence data and seeing the
implications for drug
and vaccine design you will gain
hands-on experience by analyzing curated
data
sets from public domain collections
guided by
experts with bioinformatics experience
and knowledge about biology
the goal of the omits logic program is
to provide
training in bioinformatics enabling
independent research
guided by mentors and peer example
developing a growing community with
shared passion for data driven research
and appreciation of citizen science
enabling students clinicians and faculty
of all backgrounds
to develop novel and independent
research
using latest technology in life and data
sciences
so we will combine online sessions
like we are having one today then
self-guided study materials which i will
take every one of you over in just a few
more minutes
for an immersive experience that has
proven to be effective
in our well-known and respected omix
logic programs
together with our collaborators we have
been building a growing
online community of bioinformaticians
and training
ranging from high school students to
faculty and researchers in top
universities around the world
and in all of our programs this
community
of bi-information students of biology
have access to these tools
which are here so elia has already
demonstrated the server t by info
platform and i will also demonstrate a
few of these other platforms and show
you the resources that you will have
access to
if you are joining this comments logic
program or any of our other omix logic
programs
so the bioinformatics for infectious
diseases
is a two-month program that will include
a review
of how to use analysis tools provide
examples of
infectious disease related studies and
then offer support to those interest in
working with
public domain data set of their choice
we will meet
twice a week for discussions q a
sessions and hands-on demonstrations
that everyone can participate
in so let us review the schedule and the
registration process
together so i am going to be
going to the registration link here i am
pasting it on the chat
so that you can also go along with me to
the registration page
so this is the bioinformatics for
infectious disease registration page
and this program is starting on the
ninth of november
it's a one month program and will go on
till
second december every week we'll have
two sessions and they will be timed at
9 00 a.m cst so 9 am cst
is in indian time 7 30 pm
ist you can also convert it to your
local time if you are not from
any of these regions which is either the
us or
in india so let us just move down
we have a program overview of what the
program is about
and here you can see the entire syllabus
for the different sessions
so you have the different session topics
mentioned here and the different dates
of the sessions so usually these are
all one hour sessions like we are
meeting today
where our mentors will give you
an overview of these different topics
and go in depth
on the analysis and you will carry out
the hands-on analysis on your end as
well because you will have access to the
resources which i'm going to be showing
and which also elia demonstrated earlier
and we will have different sessions as
you see right here
on these topics and you see that there
are necessary gaps
between the two sessions so that you can
go through the asynchronous
course materials that are offered as
part of this training program
to help you learn on your own and come
up with any questions that you have
and so the resources that you will have
access to
i will be coming to that one more time
so how do you register for the program
you can click on get started and there
are three membership
options which you can choose from
so the different membership options
come with uh different benefits so the
beginner options will give you access
as you see to all the different courses
that are going to be mentioned in the
program
it will give you access to the code
playground which i'm going to be showing
in
just a few more minutes and also the
interactive sessions
and the t bio info platform
the intermediate membership option will
give you access to a one-on-one
mentor session where you can request a
mentor to help you out if you have any
questions
and have a dedicated one-on-one meeting
with that expert
or the bioinformatics mentor while the
advanced membership
gives you access to another month
like not just the second december but
till
second january you will have access to
the platform
and the resources so that you can work
on your own project so i know that i saw
in the chats that
many of you are interested in working on
a covert 19 project
or a similar project on infectious
diseases
so this advanced membership would be for
you where you get
another month of access now for students
and scholars and anybody else who would
want
uh to join the program and we think that
you cannot afford we have a scholarship
program as well and i'll be sharing the
link
shortly in the chat so before that let
me move on
to the different resources that we are
going to be discussing here
so the first is the server t-bind for
platform
uh we all saw how the server t by info
platform works
so you will be able to gain access to
the platform which will not be a demo
access
but be an educational access where you
will be able to use data from public
domain data sets
like ilia was talking about earlier
and we will be carrying out hands-on
analysis
so all that elia has demonstrated in
today's session the mentors would be
taking you step by step on the different
logic of analysis in these sessions
the second platform would be the code
omix logic platform
so you can still start by registering
yourself for free on this platform there
are a few courses available
and this is our platform for practicing
r and python
in your browser so you do not need to
install an rn python but you definitely
can
do that so you have courses getting
started with bioinformatics and i know
that
a lot of students who are just learning
or starting to learn about
bioinformatics are also very much
interested in data science so
we have developed this platform where
you can easily learn about
data science in the respect of
biological data
so you will also have access to this
platform
and we will have access to what we call
an organization page
so here i have just opened a tab
on the courses so these are the
different courses that
you will have access to besides the live
trading sessions
so you will not only have access to the
program
live sessions but also the courses for
your
own uh one-on-one learning and
self-study and each of these courses
have an individual certificate
that you can get after you complete the
course
yes thank you so much elia
and i also wanted to uh
talk about the fellowship program
just for the people who are interested
in a
online internship so this is the
fellowship link
and in our research fellowship program
we have
students joining us or participants
joining us for three months
our six months research fellowship
and the focus is mainly on working on
their own projects related
to areas like neuroscience
um infectious diseases cancer biology
and more so if you have any inquiry
regarding the same you can write to us
at marketing at find out bio
you will see all of our comics logic
program comes with again
basic or advanced and the difference is
again
on the different level of access that
you get to the t by info platform here
the advanced license will allow you to
use your own data not just public domain
data use your own data
to work on your own project and you can
either do it for three months or you can
choose to do it for
six months uh that is completely up to
you
if you are interested
and here is the scholarship link that i
was talking about
that students if they are interested
and they hope that you know they want to
join the program you can fill it up
and you will see that at the bottom of
the page
you will have to provide these details
and you have to also
mention that while you're applying for
the scholarship
and you have to mention a reference from
your college or university
and we will reach out to you after you
fill up this form
and you can also choose the different
programs that you are
interested in and write down about it so
this is something that you can apply for
and as elia was mentioning and he shared
earlier
we have two groups which is the linkedin
group
where you can join and we have the
facebook group
that also you can join again because we
keep posting updates there
and as we share the link to our youtube
channel earlier
so we also have our youtube channel
where you can actually
see all the different videos so we post
a lot of informative videos
from not just our webinar sessions but
also on different topics that you can
explore right here
on the platform you can see a review so
this is a review from one of our
project interns who worked with us on a
project in glioblastoma
so you can take a look at that as well
and as i have been showing earlier
this link which i shared is a list of
project examples that people have been
able to do once they joined one
or either of these omix logic programs
so if you scroll down to the page
you will find that we have a lot of
posters
that were submitted and presented at
different
uh webinars at different conferences you
can see the different projects
here by one of our interns who
collaborated with
two of our other participants from sri
lanka and they came up with a project
on sars cove too so definitely if the
car if you're interested
you can do a project on starscope 2 as
well
then you'll have more projects the
glioblastoma project that i just
showed you earlier then you have more
projects that you can explore so please
feel free to
explore the different uh projects that
are available and that have been
actually independently developed by
participants
where we from pine biodec and our
mentors helped them throughout this
process and if you are just coming to
the platform for the first time and you
just want to
explore the different resources you can
also
take a look at our different membership
options as well
so we have a very basic membership
option
which is just for dollar 10 usd
per month it will give you access to the
tibia info platform
you won't be able to upload your own
data but you will be able to access all
the demo pipeline and run from them
and also you will be able to access 12
courses
on our platform from different sections
like transcriptomics genomics
metagenomics and epigenetics so you can
consider this option as well we also
have a specialization subscription
which will give you access to all the
courses
all the available courses on a platform
and not just selective courses
and we also have an unlimited 2.99
research license so the unlimited
membership will give you access to a
one-month
research license to the platform where
you can
actually upload your own data that you
have generated
from a lab and you can analyze that data
and also
have our team help you in that process
so you have these
options as well but again if you want to
join the bioinformatics for infectious
disease program
then here is the link and we will also
be emailing you
the link to this program and if you have
any questions related to either of these
resources
that we discussed today or any of the
other
things that you may want to seek our
help about
then you can please email us marketing
at find.bio and we will reach out to you
so now uh we will be taking in questions
so uh do we have any questions
yeah thank you very much for the
presentation i just wanted to mention
that we also
have a feedback form for those of you
that are joining
and would like to provide us with any
kind of feedback
i'm pasting the link to the forum here
in the chat
please do join us for
our upcoming free webinars so you can
stay
uh on these social media networks to uh
that beeps already mentioned on linkedin
and facebook to learn about
upcoming free webinars for those of you
that are
uh on the western time zone u.s time
zone we will have another
webinar for infectious disease research
on friday
in the afternoon so you're welcome to
join that one as well
and we regularly have these free
webinars and workshops online
uh that many of you that i see the
questions about multiple sequence
alignment or
different types of data we'll be
addressing those there as well so
again thank you very much for joining
today it was exciting to see
that so many good questions came and so
many uh different types of analysis
ideas and projects are already emerging
we hope to see all of you in the
upcoming program to be able to go into
these
different types in detail and looking
forward to interacting with you
uh so that we can learn more about your
interests which i hope
you will be able to share with us
through this forum thank you again and
thank you meepsa for doing this session
and uh and uh hope to
hope to uh you know see all of you in
the near future
yes there are courses about genomic
analysis and using machine learning we
have that
on the edu portal as uh visa showed
uh there's a a whole section on
genomics where you can learn about
genomic data
and there's also a whole series of
courses on machine learning as well
there's an introduction to machine
learning on the edu portal
and there's a whole series of courses in
r and python
where you can actually learn about the
models themselves
and you'll be able to practice
right there in the code we are just
going through our program on data
science as well
so we'll have that repeated in the
future
again thank you everyone and i hope to
see you again soon
thank you elia and thank you everyone
we'll see you
soon
thank you for joining us today
for any questions further please email
us marketing at pi dot bio